Film Courage: Going back to before you applied
to film school and what you thought was your
vision of this is where I am going to be the
next Cassavetes or whatever?
And then time moves on and was it in line
with that?
Because people think it’s going to be this
and I’m going to be driving in a BMW down
the 101.
Mark Sanderson, author/screenwriter: No, it
never is.
The romanticized image, no.
It’s more of a craftsperson job.
It’s a career but I look at it as a job
and I’m blessed to have the job.
It is my job and I’m blessed to have the
job and I’m blessed to be working.
I really like to work and I take as much work
as I can and turn down things that I don’t
like or can’t do but it’s nice to be in
a place where a producer calls you and says
“Are you available?”
I’ve also been in a place where you turn
in a thing and you say “Am I good enough?”
And you wait 6 months later and they say “I
didn’t read it yet.”
Which is the norm.
So whatever level of the business you are
working at to have any type of success (I’ve
realized is an amazing thing).
And many people can look down at (unless you’re
the highest echelon at the A-list) and say
well if you’re not that, I’m not impress
by what you do.
And so I say “Okay, I get it.
You’ve never really struggled to get one
thing made so you wouldn’t say that to someone
who has been slogging away, the 10-year-overnight-success.”
Like I said it was 6 years out of film school
(6 years) before I had my first professional
job that I was later fired from quickly.
And then 7 years for my spec to go through
all the wrong people and the spec almost won
the Nichol Fellowship and all these adventures
with that one spec.
I wrote other ones already for me to finally
end up with me sitting on the set during the
filming going “Wow!
This has been 7 years?”
And every script and project has it’s own
journey but sure out of film school I thought
they were going to hand us our diploma and
our three-picture deal (which is the joke)
which is like “Of course I’ll be working.”
Maybe as a PA which I never did.
I knew how to make films I didn’t want to
spend 18 hours a day not writing.
So I worked in restaurants as a waiter because
I could always write, you know that’s me
going through college.
But then you settle into a place where you
are finally at whatever at level you are and
have the players that you hire and the people
that you know.
But do I still want to get to higher levels,
absolutely.
But no one can take away my ability to write
and create projects.
So that’s thing so that’s the next step
would be for me to move into the producing
aspect and create projects.
So that’s the thing.
So the next step would be for me moving into
a more producing aspect.
Directing I’ve enjoyed but I probably would
have pursued it out of film school.
I really like the fact that as a writer you
can go anyone.
Like I mentioned I was in Italy last year
for 6 weeks and I was writing a screenplay.
So if you have a laptop and Internet connection
you can write anywhere but a director needs
a film crew.
I have friends who can work two years on a
movie directing it from beginning to end (it’s
a big endeavor).
I like the fact of being able to be mobile
and work and maybe do more.
This last year I had 6 movies written.
So I don’t think I could direct 6 movies
a year.
Film Courage: Yeah, it’s just so expensive.
That’s great thing about the writing, even
though sometimes they [the writer] is unappreciated,
it’s the heartbeat of the movie and you
can be on vacation while you are doing something
else like writing.
But in terms of you grew up in Southern California,
so I wonder does that taint people and not
in a bad way but in terms of the way the vision
of the way a career looks like?
Versus someone that is in another state?
Mark: Yeah, it’s weird because it never
seemed weird when my friend and I were making
movies as a kid it never seemed like such
a weird thing because we were filmmakers because
they were filming movies on our block outside.
The biggest TV shows were right up the block,
you know?
Santa Monica used to film everything there.
So we were like “Oh?”
Now if we were living in a small city some
where it might be so impressive or “I could
never make a film because it’s such a big
enormous dream.”
But it was right outside our door so we were
like “Huh?”
In a good way or bad because you don’t know
if you’re ever going to be able to do it
and achieve and sustain that.
So I think the wide-eyed dreamer is still
inside and I need that as a kid but then you
grow up and you realize the realities of the
business.
Who wants to spend millions of dollars and
lose their money on their idea.
You know it’s a business unfortunately but
if you can work in it as artists.
And some are blessed to be an “artiste,”
an “auteur.”
And others are people who get to work.
And if I’m working in the film business
I’m a happy person.
Film Courage: Do you think you realize the
amount of time spent alone at a computer or
at a desk?
I mean I realize you can be in a cafe writing
and for a lot of people that does work.
But do you think a lot of people realize being
bound by this calendar?
The calendar that says “Okay, I need this
done by this date and I can’t deviate from
that.
Mark: Well in school or college you have a
report or whatever do.
There are do dates for everything but that
made it seem more like a job.
Which in the past it seemed more romanticized
like “I’ll sell my specs, I sell it and
there will be some weird thing that happens
where you won’t have to work so hard because
you did the work, right?
You sold spec with all the rewrites and the
possibilities that can happen.
Then when you start working in the business
you start realizing all the possibilities
that do happen and you’re like “Oh wow?”
And it sort of knocks down the shimmer of
this romanticized driving with the top down…I
had a convertible one time…
Film Courage: [Laughs] I don’t know why
that came into my head?
Mark: No, it was a 1965 Buick which was beautiful
and I would drive up the coast.
And you know driving on the lot and all this
stuff you dream of but then you still have
to do the work and like I said I worked with
a lot of “Actors” back in the restaurant
days who didn’t want to do the work.
They loved you know [takes an imaginary drag
off of a cigarette and exhales] “I’m an
actor.”
Brooding and this.
“Are you taking classes?”
“Well no?
I went on this audition because I have a good
look.”
And I’m like “Oh, so you just don’t
want to do the work?
Or you think it’s just that easy?”
So yeah, it’s changed, the perception I
think off once you work at something where
you have this outside perception that many
people might have of “How amazing it is
to be a writer!”
Yeah, it is but as a writer take the Hollywood
element out, it’s a grind.
You’ve got to write.
You’ve got to come up with stuff.
35 scripts, I’m like “How did I channel
that many stories through this body into these
things?”
And then I go “There won’t be any others
in the well, how could there be?”
Well that’s your job as a writer, right?
To come up with another story, to come up
with another, right?
I mean that’s the beautiful part of it to
come back to the well and have it be full
of stuff and that’s where your living comes
into play, your experiences and living an
authentic life where you are always observing
and doing things because it’s your homework
as a screenwriter to do that.
Because you don’t want to go back to your
well and have it be empty.
That’s when your passion dries up and you’re
like “I’ve got nothing to say.
What am I doing?”
And you shrink and you just disappear.
And I think while you’re trying to pursue
your career you have to live an interesting
life and meet interesting people and have
it all relate back to your screenwriting because
it does.
It’s your job to live an interesting, authentic
life and I think that helps your work.
Question For The Viewers: Is your Hollywood
career unfolding the way you imagined it would?